just what bring your story now and this
is about wildlife protection that's in
the papers today and we've got a
fascinated scientific device which has
been developing to talk to the inventor
of that very very shortly but there you
are it's about the RAI spy yeah this is
an article in the mirror today that's
been picked up by quite a few of the
papers and this is a camera that's being
inserted into the horn of rhinos in
South Africa where they're saying that
every six hours of rhino is being
butchered either for their you know
medicine for six long and three six
hours and they're saying that poaching
has increased 9,000 fold since 2007 and
that they could be completely extinct
within a decade if they carry on at this
rate so they're trying to curb the
attack if you like what do you hear this
I mean in the studio now we've honored
to be speaking to Steve Backshall who's
a wildlife presenter and he's obviously
very very interested in this but we want
to go to the manage developed all of
this bio skype the cameras inventor
that's dr. Paul Donahue and doctor
Donahue is a lecturer and biological
sciences at the University of Chester
and Isabel just give us those statistics
they're just just scary
um one Rhino is butchered every six
hours in Africa how will your device
explain to me doctor how your advice
will slow this up if not stockless good
so this will allow us to detect the
second line of post so we think this is
the missing link in the kind of battle
against lineup protein and this will
should complement other existing
strategies and make the whole system a
bit more effective but what a don't
understand doctor is okay I can
understand the Rhino having a tracking
device on it and indeed a camera but is
the camera constantly being monitored
hard you actually know that the Rhino is
being attacked as opposed to sleeping so
divide the cameras para system that also
incorporates a heart rate monitor so
we'll know when the Rhino is shot the
heart rate monitor will trigger the
camera to come on to start recording
evidence and then the answer a and
reporting units will be deployed to go
to the party scene but by then it will
be too late won't it
plannin it'll be too late by then the me
the Reiner will be dead by then so what
happens is most most vandals are not
post individually so normally people go
on a space of poaching so the Rhinos
will so we will get to the scene
immediately and apprehend our poachers
which will stop the from poaching
further vinyls and we hope the main
aspect of these projects is we hold this
latter two determinants so when you turn
a shooter I know what you want you won't
pull the trigger basically okay I've got
Steve Backshall the white life presenter
here to speak to you as well doctor and
I'm wondering this is obviously shows
quite how bad the situation is that you
can be thinking about targeting
individual rhinos and you can be
targeting particular subspecies of
rhinos or are you going across the
entire group this is this is part of a
big team of people basically an
international team of people and after
the work is being done in six you in the
country of origins to be honest so it
was work going on in South Africa and
work going on in Asia as well so yes
it's an underground project that will
hopefully work on a global scale well
good luck to you dr. donahue and all
that you're trying to do with this it's
called rapid real-time anti poaching
intelligence device good luck with it
thank you very much ngratulations to
everyone at the University of Chester
who developed this one and I suppose the
hope Steve is that they'll be able to
use it on polar bears on tigers and
lions and other things as well
and I think at the moment they're very
much focusing on rhino because this is a
group that is at extreme danger right
now mostly because the horn itself is
used it's ground up and used is pretty
much a panacea throughout most of the
East it's also used for Yemeni dagger
handles as well and some of the
subspecies of rhino are down to the last
few dozen animals so you have got to a
situation where actually you know
following one individual animal is is
still critical and that will be used
alongside methods like removing the
horns from animals with drones as well
so there's lots of old trials on the
next six to nine months
south africa steve appreciate your take
thank you very much indeed